[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
miss de ville d'arcachon encore le
touquet ces villes balnéaires ont vu se
développer la pratique de la
villégiature au milieu du xviiie siècle
à l'époque réservé à une élite
aristocratique
c'était plutôt un lieu de sociabilité
puis la coutume du banc de mer va
apparaître d'abord pour des raisons
dites on médical alors évidemment pas du
tout comme nous aujourd'hui
donc il ya des images très amusante de
dames avec des maillots très couvrants
qui sortent de leur cabine n'a vraiment
rien à voir avec nos petits bikinis qui
sont d'ailleurs aussi évoqué dans
l'exposition tous à la plage ville
balnéaire du xviiie siècle à nos jours
retrace l'architecturé l'urbanisme des
bords de mer en france cette exposition
itinérante produite par la cité de
l'architecturé du patrimoine est visible
jusqu'au 8 mai au palais du roi de rome
à rambouillet beaucoup d'image qui
présente les différentes pratiques des
vacances en bord de mer dès qu'on arrive
dans des périodes plus récentes et bien
chacun on peut se peut s'y retrouver
plus retrouver l'image du village de
vacances qui là qu'il a pu voir enfants
là peut rêver aussi au grand hôtel des
panneaux explicatifs et des vidéos
illustrent notamment la mode balnéaire
dans les années 1920 1930
[Musique]
c'est l'époque dans l'entre-deux-guerres
on commence à s'exposer au soleil donc
il commence vraiment à voir des
vêtements dédiés à cette pratique de la
plage en fait donc les premiers mâts
vrai maillot demain alors très couvrant
bien sûr encore pour des questions de
pudeur mais quand même des ateliers pour
enfants autour de l'exposition seront
organisées du 25 avril au 8 mai au
programme reconstitution de cabines de
plage ou encore création de leur propre
collection de maillots de bain